[Music]
we got our tinfoil hats on y'all
literally marble he's got his on bunnies
got hers on peachy and Kermit have
theirs on they all have tinfoil hats no
just Bobby does do you need a tinfoil
hat do you not have tinfoil
well postmates some go to i'm sorry i'm
on post mates use code jamming Julian
for a hundred and ten dollars of free
delivery credits in your first seven
days it is an awesome delivery app could
you could you leave it on what we need
protection here check it out also guys
get yourself some Andy's the softest
under well you can buy three times
softer than cotton right now you get 15%
off your first pair free shipping and a
100% satisfaction guarantee go to meet
undies dot-com / Angela and I click the
link down below me and ease makes
everything great and soft and
comfortable so do it check it out thank
you sponsors Jenna what are we doing
today well so I know you guys are
excited wearing tin foil hats but
they're not like conspiracy theories or
anything like that it's I've been
watching this show you know like I do
called NASA's unexplained files
and I've been having a great time
because it's just he doesn't want to
wear that I'll just put it next to him
yeah they go boy
I just am fascinated by everything that
I am NOT currently aware of right yeah
and I just was watching that show and
you know 3:00 in the morning or whenever
I watch it and just taking notes of the
things that I like and a couple of
things that weren't on that show that I
like okay
and we're only wearing tinfoil hats just
because fun right sometimes you just got
to put some tinfoil on your head podcast
that is a good time
it did some really enjoying myself yeah
you are thank you let's do it I'm ready
to hear what you got I want to know some
stuff I like stuff I like stuff yeah
like when you learn something that you
didn't know before that's my favorite
feeling yeah hell yeah all right are you
ready I'm [ __ ] ready are you ready oh
my god so ready
are you okay yeah we're trying to figure
out is this affecting the way I think
you think I don't know we also drink
energy drinks earlier I feel feel kind
of crazy what what do you know the name
of that brand of energy drink no how
many milligrams like caffeine is in
there yes okay all right Julian yeah go
a couple good I had tequila last night
and energy drink today and we lost an
hour to daylight savings was like a good
day to wear okay I'm ready all right so
the first thing that I learned on what
Julian the first thing that I learned on
this show was the possibility or the
idea what the theory
Julian of the Sun our son
we loved him he was great he's a good
guy Julian yeah pay attention I'm
looking for him
gotta make a layup pay attention Oh
grace the son having an evil twin do you
know what they call this evil twin stop
laughing with each other do you know
what they call it no nemesis
they call it nemesis call it nemesis
like they refer to it as the son's
nemesis or that's its name nemesis Oh
are you ready okay this is from directly
from NASA's unexplained files of the
show roughly half of the stars you see
stop doing I'm focusing roughly half of
the stars you see in the night sky
Julian are called binary stars they have
companion stars with them they orbit
with each other yeah
we are relatively unusual in that we can
only see one son and only have one son
that's our so y'all go like this around
it's ours
there's a couple of scientific teams
that have evidence that there is
something big lurking on the outside of
our solar system Julian it looks like
every 26 million years or so give or
take there's a big major extinction on
earth suggesting a pattern or that it
happens periodically and it suggests
that maybe there's an astronomical cause
for it so what's something that could
cause something like that every 26
million years on the dot well yeah kind
of on the dot yeah theoretically a
second stars massive gravitational pull
could be slinging stuff towards the
earth every 26 million years but it has
to be massive okay maybe there's
something giant lurking on the outside
of our universe and maybe maybe Julian
it's a giant Sun called nemesis but the
reason you can't see it because it's
infrared light it's infrared light
infrared light oh my god so it's there
mm-hmm so if you have an infrared camera
maybe you could see it could you see it
yeah you know um I was sort of not
really paying attention when they went
over the infrared satellite part but
basically you can't see with the eyes
you can see with the telescope okay but
it could be there he'll be there it
could be there okay okay see now I have
a question um I don't know if I have an
answer well go for it you imagine you
had like an infrared scope or something
yeah could you look through the scope
into a telescope and would that turn the
telescope into an infrared telescope
you know I don't know and I'm pretty
sure that they have plenty of things
that can see an infrared light but but
what if this is just otherworldly
infrared light it's just different like
we don't have the tech to see it yeah
huh is it as big as the Sun maybe or
bigger as thick or smaller or thicker or
less thick do they hmm
is it hot
Oh hmm okay I got I'm down yeah I'm on
board here look it the mrs. star theory
is what it's called I mean I have a
tinfoil hat on but it's it's fun is it
not no it's fun right okay
here's from space.com okay I don't know
if that's a reputable have the websites
that I pulled some of this stuff from
have like you know things that sound
like that but I'm not sure if it's like
a reputable source at all whatsoever
because someone just be like I like
science.com
can you buy stars on space.com I don't
know okay nemesis is a theoretical dwarf
star oh okay a dwarf star so it'd be
dead right Oh check space.com some of
these things Julian I'm telling I'm like
literally too dumb to explain them to
you that's fine I'm cute I'm not have
them be explained to me so Larry good
team their nemesis is a theoretical
dwarf star thought to be a companion to
our son the theory was postulated to
explain a perceived cycle of mass
extinctions in Earth's history
scientists speculated that such a star
could affect the orbit of objects in our
far outer solar system sending them on a
collision course with earth
while recent astronomical surveys failed
to find any evidence that such a star
exists a 20-17 study suggests there
could be a nemesis in the very ancient
past here's the argument for nemesis in
the early 1980s scientists noticed that
extinctions seem to follow a cyclical
pattern every 27 million years or so in
1984 Richard Muller of the University of
California Berkeley suggests that a red
dwarf star 1.5 light-years away could be
the cause of mass extinctions and that
it's a white dwarf low mass star only a
few times as massive as Jupiter and
would cast dim light making it difficult
to spot so we don't know where he is
Wow we don't know where he be lurking
them be lurking what the hell
scientists speculated that the nemesis
that nemesis may affect the Oort cloud
which is made up of icy rocks
surrounding the Sun beyond the range of
Pluto
many of these chunks travel around the
Sun in a long-term elliptical orbit as
they draw closer to the star their ice
begins to melt and stream behind them
making them recognizable as comets if
nemesis traveled through the Oort cloud
every 27 million years some argue it
could kick extra comets out of the
sphere and send them hurling towards the
inner solar system and earth impact
rates would increase and mass
extinctions would be more common so in
in the event like say the 26 million
year timer was up today right yep
would we would we would the earth be
like shaking would it be like such a
massive impact to where we actually like
saw things flying and then felt it and
like or what would it just be some sort
of like slow and gradual well Julian
mass extinction implies that something
so big so bad happens that we by the
time it happens we probably although
yeah we just bye-bye
oh can we watch it I don't think so bad
so mass extinction like just poof
don't ever everything's gone well I
don't think it's exactly like poof it's
more like bang but ya paying energy it's
just a giant bang energy can that flies
towards Earth with the guy's face on it
it's just bang oh okay um this ties into
my last one but I don't know how to say
this word okay you IP are PE R QP R
Cooper Cooper Cooper maybe creeper
creeper creeper creeper creeper creeper
okay where'd you made up creeper creeper
it's like creeper boat oh he's a creepy
creeper okay so um the quipu belt Cooper
I just call it to like simplify things
just call creeper
that belt okay
I built a disk of debris that lies
inside the solar system also has a
well-defined outer edge this is super
cool
that could be sheared off by a companion
star researchers have found other
systems where a companion star seems to
have affected the shape of the debris
disk so there's basically like I think
it's outside of Neptune we'll get to
this at the end but there's a bunch of
debris floating out there okay and then
all of a sudden it just [ __ ] ends
like it just stops why because usually
if stuff's like sort of floating through
space yeah you would expect it to sort
of oh like it hits an invisible wall
kind of got it on so people argue that
maybe that there's something huge over
here that's causing them to get sucked
towards it which would create a drop-off
in that space got it that we wouldn't be
able to physically see but it's there
but that's that's the the creeper that's
interesting
mmm okay what is this AI says the dwarf
planet
Sedna lends further credence in the eyes
of some to the existence of a companion
star for the Sun with an orbit of up to
12,000 years the planet presents a
puzzle to many scientists suggests that
a massive object such as a dim star
could be responsible for keeping Sedna
so far from the Sun okay okay I got that
and then we'll talk about planet 9 or
should we just talk about planet I now
know about planet I know what good well
here's here's I guess it says a theory
under fire though some scientists find
the Nemesis Theory plausible others do
not
the initial cyclical nature of mass
extinctions is still under discussion
studies of craters seem to indicate that
such a pattern does not exist other
studies of fossil records suggest that
mass extinctions are more likely to
happen around those Peaks though
extinction events occur during other
time periods in order to avoid
significantly affecting the
orbit of planets as well as to avoid
observation nemesis must remain at a
distance from the Sun but as rahmanir
astronomers argue that such an orbit
would be inherently unstable traveling
so far out nemesis would be affected by
other stars moving through the galaxy
yeah that was kind of my question is if
it's outside of our solar system like
how does it stay in orbit or within
orbits range if it's not like within do
you know what I mean to answer that
question anyone okay anyways the
resulting orbit would not provide a
steady kick to the Oort cloud but would
be constantly changing in 2017 and news
a new study suggested that nearly all
stars like the Sun were born with
companions the astronomers did detailed
studies of young stars and the Perseus
molecular cloud and backed up their work
with modeling but nemesis if it did
indeed exist at the time broke free of
the Sun early in its history and moved
to the rest of the Milky Way the Milky
Way's population okay that's an
interesting theory the one that the
stars are paired with like a companion
star you're my binary star you're my
binary star I'm nemesis okay you can
only see me with infrared light cube
here's some more about that because a
solar companion may be hard to find but
it would still be visible by sensitive
telescopes astronomers have scoured the
sky using two micron all-sky surveys to
mass which studied the sky over four
years in three infrared wavelengths the
instrument discovered 173 brown dwarfs
farther away than our solar system but
none near enough to be the infamous
nemesis micellar dona don't tip your
tinfoil cap at me Masoli companion oh no
no no no no okay let's talk about planet
9 fun planet 9 planet 10 on a month on
planet 1213 planet 14 planet 15 planet
16
just counting planet yeah okay cool I'm
trying to get I'm trying to get them
organized Oh are they are they organized
they were at one point I'm trying to get
them back into the right order okay go
okay this is from a website called
science focus calm which I can calm it
might be reputable but we don't know
yeah
could just be some guy named Jared over
here being like science focused calm all
right planet nine could an enormous
world be lurking in our astronomers say
astronomers are increasingly certain
that there is a ninth planet stop doing
that here your eyebrows in your tinfoil
I love having audible eyebrows I'm sorry
horrible eyebrows been named nice thank
you
astronomers are increasingly certain but
there is a ninth planet orbiting the Sun
far out beyond Neptune a so called
planet 9 it wouldn't be the first time
all right this is some weird stuff can
you stop this so distracting so this is
essentially the theory that MIT stop
it's not a Sun on the outside but maybe
a planet yeah okay sort of the same idea
that there's something big out there
that's causing these things to be pulled
in that direction I'm a firm believer
that Pluto is still playing at 9'o I
never let him go our boy Pluto my boy
Pluto
when series
I think series Cee re s the largest
asteroid in the solar system was
discovered in 1801 it was initially
classified as a planet but later down
now downgraded Pluto to was admitted to
the planet club upon its discovery in
1930
only two have been asked to leave in
2006 relegated to dwarf planet status
yeah yeah
[ __ ] dude we did Pluto so dirty yeah
there what my childhood that was my
favorite planet really I liked him hey
uh I know you've been part of our thing
here for like a million years but get
out please leave don't let the door hit
you on the way out Pluto the first clues
that there's yet another member of the
Suns planetary fraternity came in 2014
Julian that's just from science focus
calm okay I'm trying to focus here I'm
just tied to being a fat baby stop in
2014 when American astronomer dr. Scott
Shepherd found a small dwarf planet
candidate called 2012 VP 113 orbiting on
an average of 250 times further from the
Sun than the earth it's elongated orbit
which is significantly tilted relative
to that of the other planets immediately
stood out
nothing is currently known in the solar
system that could create its orbit while
a few unusually aligned objects could be
dismissed as an unlikely coincidence now
a total of 10 have been discovered
largely thanks to work by astronomer dr.
Mike Brown and dr. Constantine but begin
at the California Institute of
Technology with all these objects
sharing similar similar orbital
properties the chances of their
alignment being a fluke
drops to just 0.0001 percent wow that's
low the leading explanation is that
there is an otherwise unseen planet
hurting these objects with its gravity
Shepard was 60 percent sure a ninth 60
percent what how did a ninth planet
existed back when he found 2012 VP 113
now he says he's 85 percent certain yet
for the planet to be acting in this way
it would have to be 10 times more
massive than the earth take at least 10
years to orbit the Sun and sit over 200
times further out than our planet this
enormous distance makes hunting it down
and photographing it tricky right yeah
for us to see planet 9 light has to Trek
all the way out there from the Sun and
almost all the way back again fading all
the while but astronomers have been able
to narrow the search using several clear
shortcuts for example data from the
Cassini mission to Saturn was used to
rule out parts of the outer solar solar
system
if planet 9 was in those areas then the
probe would have picked them up or they
would have picked up small gravitational
discrepancies there was a small setback
in September 2018 when new research
showed that another technique for ruling
out parts of the sky wasn't feasible but
the hunt goes on so far we have covered
about 30 percent of the prime area the
planet could be in it will take about
another four years to cover the rest
only four years four years we're close
then we very close we're like right
there we should check back what do you
think I am very interested in this I'm
invested right I think it's interesting
the concept of like everything adding up
in terms of this theory of it being
there but the fact that light fades at
that distance like there's no
confirmation of it that's crazy to me
fine it hurts my head a little bit
that's why I have this hat on it is fun
imagine light fading because you're
travelling so far of a distance fun damn
that's interesting it is fun right yeah
I just hope it's nemesis I mean it'd be
cool if it was playing at 9:00 but I'm
really hoping for a nemesis son an
emesis would be really cool imagine if
we had two sons we could vacation like
way out there and take and get a tan
from nemesis a nemesis tan you just turn
blue everywhere why would you turn blue
because it's infrared so infrared light
makes your skin blue very blue cite your
sources
space.com
nice Gillian thanks you know what else
is blue what me Andes if you choose a
blue pair of me undies me Andes is three
times softer than cotton and it doesn't
fade like light fades when it's
traveling to nemesis and/or Planet nine
and back munities lasts they last long
and they're very comfortable
they make blue green purple designs
anything you want they have our door
they have socks they have the most
comfortable onesies on planet Earth or
also nemesis I don't think nemesis has
anything more comfortable than munities
um my source is space comm Julian so if
you buy me undies now there's a chance
that you might be more comfortable than
anything on nemesis currently I'm 90%
sure I'm 60% sure of it and if you don't
believe me go to space comm actually
just go to my undies calm /join and
Julian and you get 15% off your first
order purchase of an underwear or a
double pair of underwear for you and
your special someone who both want to be
more comfortable than anything on
nemesis or Planet nine I'm sixty percent
sure you will so hit the link down below
and get started with me at ease you
won't go back to regular underwear
afterwards also guys I don't think they
you can post much things from nemesis
but I'm not I'm also not sure that you
can't post nice things from nemesis cuz
you know I'm sixty percent sure you
might be able to post mates to nemesis
so depends on what kind of restaurants
they have or there's just a restaurant
named nemesis in which case I wouldn't
probably wouldn't eat there cuz it
sounds like why would you name a
restaurant nemesis is it just like a
really spiteful chef that got kicked out
from another restaurant and then he's
like I'm gonna start a restaurant called
nemesis it's all dick all of my nemesis
is recipe notice I put upside down and
backwards you know what his name is mr.
clapper postmates is the delivery app
that makes getting your favorite foods
from your favorite restaurants easily
brought to your front door it is so
seamless we use it all the time whether
we're ordering lunch dinner or even just
some ingredients that we need from a
store but we don't feel like running out
or we can't run out since we work from
home
so check it out download the post mates
app in the answer
use code Jana Julian you get a hundred
and ten dollars of free delivery credits
for your first seven days when you use
that code I'm telling you it is the best
delivery app and you will not want to
switch to anything and you not want to
get in your car and go to the grocery
store or pick up takeout food ever again
because it makes it so easy so check it
out hit the link down below or enter
code Jenna and Julian and your post
mates the end right I'm trying to figure
out how to say this so we can end this
Piper Kuiper belt oh you were away off
well why is there a you then you know I
mean Kuiper belt creepy clapping I think
it's her accent she sounds like she's
from nemesis is that nemesis accent okay
well we're not gonna do is call people
nemesis accent alright alright hippie
here's a quick one okay
a little one quickie this is from live
science god these sources just get
better and better baby what's better
than a moon two months a moon orbiting a
loon which the Internet has dubbed a
moment also known as supplements Mooney
toast grandmum's moon it's and Moon Moon
Moon are still only theoretical but
recent calculations suggest that there's
nothing impossible about their formation
see if you don't believe that they
recently calculated it so you're wrong
Julianne there's 60% people that make
also I'm gonna start a new website
called I promise this is science calm I
think that'll be your next service I
swear it's science doc no I swear
I swear it's ' no no it's
science.com okay there's definitely not
one org I think your computer's hacked
it should be working okay anyways do you
like the idea of movement I like what
was Mooney toast that's my favorite yeah
I like Mooney toast but actually that
doesn't make sense because isn't eat
dough in Spanish like a smaller thing so
is the moon is the mini-moon mini-moon
is the moon eat oh oh
got it it is a mini moon so it's not an
identical twin
I like moon moon and I like moon with
four hours it's really easy to say but
like what if our moon had a tiny little
moon orbiting it so would that affect
like the weather and stuff on the moon
well I mean I think we'll get there
later about having two moons but yeah it
would affect because the moon affects
our weather well the term doesn't have
an atmosphere right so it doesn't have
weather that's true it's just pretty
much space right yeah yeah so it
wouldn't affect the weather on say you
build a sandcastle on the moon and the
moon comes around or you're eating
cheese the moods made of cheese so if
you're eating cheese maybe the moon
makes the cheese taste different the
cheese hits different on the moon when
the moon's around I'm sixty percent
surety of 60 percent sure you don't even
tell us a story like okay well there was
one night that we hold on what if it's
spelled M oh oh but there's a [ __ ]
apostrophe or what's the accent accent
on the second second alone so there was
one night huh
when a cow jumped over the moon and as
he jumped over the moon the moon rotated
around the cow who's going Moo over the
moon and as the moon passed by the cow
Moo no the cow went move but because the
moon was there
elevated the cow further off of the
surface of the moon so that at that
point the cow was actually jumping over
the moon not the moon yes and since the
moon is so small the cows bigger than
the moon much smaller than the moon then
you have a situation where the cow is
circling the moon and then the cow is
part of the moon so circling and
rotating around our moon is a cow
jumping over the moon in a perpetual
state forever
that's incredible it's just swinging and
swinging Wow
the end amazing
we should write that as a children's
book and just make it mad [ __ ]
confusing sorry yeah how about the cow
jumped over the moon
no no read about the moon okay let's
move on you know as fascinating as that
was Julian we should move on speaking of
moves here there's a theory yep
that maybe our moon hasn't always been
one moon oh wow that it was multiple
moons two moons tremens
maybe five this is from this is from the
show six months Julian I mean crazy
seven months that's just crazy okay hear
me out
nine months that's just noon no I'm
gonna change my name I'm gonna change my
face I'm gonna change my name
you know like the writer like RL Stein
I'm gonna change my name to I am like RL
but I am scientist and I'm gonna write a
book on the moon written by I am
scientist I am scientist I don't know
I'm just I'm trying to be respectful of
the pronunciations of our completely
fictitious million moons
okay I'm sorry Julian
yeah this directly from the show NASA's
unexplained files
great show by the way I'm super I really
like it there's been reports throughout
history like the Romans marching into
battle of seeing two moons in our sky
yeah that was that possible we know it's
not would not have been possible for
there to be two moons during the Roman
Empire but is it possible in theory at
one point during our Earth's history
that there was more than one moon and
there's no like other celestial body big
enough for people to mistake it for the
moon even when Mars is its closest and
its orbit to the earth no one would be
like oh that's the other moon but we are
unusual and that we only have one moon
like Jupiter and Saturn have 60 moons
and a lot of them are weirdo like
do weird stuff the data suggests that
earth at one time was hit with an object
the size of Mars and that the debris
color that's kind of big Mars is Mars
Mars been hitting the gym a little bit
getting big the debris yeah coalesced
into an object the formed the moon okay
but we don't know if it all coalesce at
once into one moon what if it coalesce
into two where the moon binman or three
months where they been then to an other
do they're there but they're just not
there but now we only have one moon I do
agree with one part of that what
sentence or kind of a bunch of sentences
would be a paragraph I presume we are
unusual that's all that's right Thank
You Julian isn't it a cool idea though
of the debris that formed from that
impact forming multiple moons that then
coalesced into our moon which would
explain why
I one side of the moon has very
different crust than the other side of
the Moon I like how you use the word
crust Julian what let's not talk about
sandwiches okay or pizza maybe okay okay
so just to kind of explain this to me
like I'm five you have a ball of cheese
and you throw it at a big hard ball and
it blows up and it's explosive a million
pieces of cheese not a million pieces
whatever hold on a million pieces of
cheese of those million pieces there's
one pretty big piece and then there's a
couple like smaller pieces that is what
you're seeing the big piece is the moon
that we know and then the little ones
are like no baby moon's well maybe for
all of them are baby moons I mean we was
already there so if the earth yeah and
something the size of Mars okay
impacted with each other yeah you'd have
a lot of debris yes and some of it would
be chunks some of it would be small some
of it would probably be pretty big huh
as it's spinning around the earth that
still you know lived and remained intact
yeah sort of I guess or we became parent
or whatever there's pieces that because
they're floating around the
gravitational pull they get smushed
together and you know create a sphere
and create a ball like the moon because
of the gravity you know what I mean
so is it possible that at one point like
maybe multiple things coalesced into
moons and then those look at those two
things smashed in with each other and
the moon yeah I think that's I mean I
think that's possible as long as like
for a moon to be a moon does it need to
be comprised of something specific or
can anything like with a gravitational
orbit I'm too dumb to answer that
because whatever Mars is made of or
something that's not March there's
something the size of Mars was made of
is going to determine if it has on a on
a molecular level because I'm a
scientist with the tinfoil hat if this
can actually be classified as a moon
right like it has to be made of
something specific
can't just be any I don't really answer
that that's just my first question but I
completely hear the theory it's
interesting as far well so if we had two
moons at one point all the gravity on
earth like that not the gravity but like
we would have tidal waves and storms and
all kinds of stuff because all of our
you know water and stuff is being pulled
earlier so it'd be pretty crazy here but
lucky for us my dude we only have one
month what one moon I mean that's the
thing right like if the weather were to
start just going off the rails out of
nowhere people would be like what's
going on there must be a second moon
well if it was going off the rails cuz
we had a second moon it would be like
people wouldn't be talking about it we'd
be dying
how how die how die like in tidal wave
tsunamis huge storms like really really
that's what I mean like if the weather
had a crazy shift and we were like it
was yeah it's dangerous people would die
but I'm saying like it would the first
thought would be like damn there must be
a second moon or them first one's gone
crazy
oh there wouldn't be any thoughts we we
would be in we'd all die OB apocalypse
maybe not apocalypse but like really
really bad disasters okay okay
what are you ready to move on yeah okay
what apocalypse cue lips Julian yeah
have you ever heard of a black hole cut
yeah yeah is this on yeah have you ever
heard of a white hole
why is it something so weird oh wait oh
no okay
here's one that girl is genuinely too
dumb to explain like I watched like
three youtube videos and I'm telling you
I am too dumb to explain what the hell
is done all right that's fine I watched
videos that made me feel like the
dumbest person on the planet are killing
dumb yeah I mean watch a video about a
white hole if you really just want to be
humbled into some stupid okay cuz that's
what that makes me feel like this is
from Wikipedia okay so don't ask me to
explain it because I literally [ __ ]
care okay white planet Julie a white
hole is a hypothetical region of
space-time in singularity which cannot
be entered from the outside although
energy matter and light can escape from
it in this sense it is the reverse of a
black hole which can be entered only
from the outside and from which energy
and matter and light cannot escape white
holes appear in the theory of external
black holes in addition to a black hole
region in the future which such a
solution of the Einstein field equations
has a white hole region in the past stay
with me
however some believe this region does
not exist for black holes and that have
formed through gravitational collapse
nor are there any known physical
processes through which a white hole
could be formed supermassive black holes
are theoretically predicted to be at the
center of every galaxy and that possibly
a galaxy can't exist without one it's
been proposed by Stephen Hawking that
these super massive black holes spawned
with supermassive white holes / Big Bang
birth of a new universe Big Bang birth
been named called it Julian certain
formulations even suggest that white
holes have an event horizon in the past
while a black hole has an event or
horizon in the future if correct white
holes would be time reversed black holes
which particles can only escape and
never return we haven't seen one and
it's inconclusive because we don't
really know what we're looking for but
some cosmologists
believe the Big Bang could have been a
white hole spitting out information from
another universe to our own okay that
sentence alone justifies our hats that's
what you just said out of your mouth
that is why we're wearing these hats I
have a question if you're a teacher I'm
the student here
if we were to make a Venn diagram of
black holes and white holes what would
we find in the middle this is not a
riddle I'm just trying to shed light on
like what like what the similarities
between the two would be is it like a
there's a void of something in a black
hole and a white hole right they just
well so the YouTube video that I watched
and I'm lit I do not know how to answer
your questions without like I'm sort of
just talking telling you that I'm
probably terribly wrong because I am too
dumb to explain it that's fine I was
fully even understand what they're
talking about
I get it but the YouTube video that I
watched basically showed a a black hole
here and the very edge of it is the
event horizon okay and time and space
would act very differently as you're
passing through it weird [ __ ] weird
yeah well in it I'm too dumb it's fine
I'm just too dot so that's what the
event horizon is that they're going to
it's like the passage of when you
actually go into it okay I think what
they have in common is that they're a
supermassive black hole or a black hole
I think they describe as what happens
when the nucleus or whatever I'm a
planet like it actually dies and then
employs the black hole yeah that's right
yeah because my idea of a black hole is
something that sucks everything into it
not even light can escape yeah but the
reverse of that is this white hole where
things can only be like expelled from it
but I don't I don't think it's like what
your brain wants to do is think that a
black hole goes this way
on the other side of it is a white hole
that spews it out somewhere yeah because
that's what makes sense yeah but it's
not that I don't think what's crazy like
what if though that event horizon is is
like sort of like the universal it's
like a clock right like so
anytime something interacts with the
event horizon in a white hole it doesn't
go physically anywhere but instead it's
like propelled into a different
dimension or time period I have no idea
this whole thing about the like infinite
future and infinite paths like really
[ __ ] with me yeah because I watched
this video where they have a graph yes
yeah and we're in the middle of it
uh-huh
and it's pointed like a square yeah but
tilted so it's a diamond yeah and
there's infinite future an infinite pass
and like the singularity is the side and
if I flip it over then it's space-time
yeah like it's really difficult to
fathom for sure unless you understood
this on like some type of mathematical
scale or sure I actually I don't want to
watch that too dumb to understand yeah
but it's really cool and the idea of an
infinite future and an infinite pass was
really hard to understand or grasp or
make any sense of and the same with
space and time and absolutely I think
the space-time conversation and white
holes and things like that like that to
me is one of the most interesting things
that you can even just like let your
brain go wild and think about yeah
because there are literally infinite
possibilities for different planes of
existence that have time similar to the
one we're experiencing and like things
like white holes just expand that idea
yeah the way that this graph what if I
think yeah I'm too dumb to do don't know
you're not a scientist that's fine it's
okay
I think what he was saying on the
singularity part is at some point
there's a period where time acts like
space and space acts like time
yeah it's just really like its grasp
your hat I think there's no law in my
hat
probably you got to put this on dude
that mean that is so [ __ ] crazy yeah
but I don't understand it and I do think
that if you're interested that there's
fun stuff you could watch from people
far more qualified that have a lot
better information than what I just said
which is on Wikipedia where that there
is in the math in theory black holes we
kind of in the people in science agree
exists or probably exists yeah and you
know that girl took a photograph of one
recently right so we we agree
black holes exists and we think we
understand somewhat how they act a
little bit and that light can't even
escape them and I think I had correct me
if I'm wrong I don't know anything but I
think that it's been theorized are like
heavily supported that a black hole
sucks in stuff and that it doesn't go
anywhere else yeah just that it
disappears yeah or what disappears from
us or from where it was but it goes into
the black hole which means who knows
well I think that it it's been
theoretically shown yeah it doesn't go
anywhere
yes yeah that it's not like oh it comes
out the other side and goes to this
place it's gone it's gone yeah so when I
heard a white hole I was like oh [ __ ]
so it's spitting out [ __ ] from a black
hole yeah because it that makes sense
right yeah that's when your brain wants
to do but it's not it's not yeah that's
[ __ ] wildly fun that one's really fun
that one's my favorite so far but like
that it just it blows my mind but in the
theory the math shows that if a black
hole exists that also there would be
this white hole
is the mirror opposite both in the the
space-time of it and its properties of
how things can only go this way yeah
yeah how it interacts with things
[ __ ] crazy dude certain formulations
even suggest that white holes have an
event horizon in the past where a black
hole has an event horizon in the future
if correct white holes would be time
reversed black holes from which
particles can only escape and never it
would like propelled so [ __ ] a reverse
event horizon so with a white hole you
you're thrust it back into the space
time continuum backwards and with a
black hole theoretically you'd be
thrusted the other way yeah I don't know
that's still insane but yeah if you're
interested in that there's some good
stuff you can read or watch I literally
can't explain it yeah my brain is like
it's really working all three of my
brain cells working pretty hard and I'm
keeping them in here that's Reilly ain't
going anywhere
I have tin foiled them in here y'all
[ __ ] thought you could leave all
right do you want one more that's like
fun they're not not heavy and it won't
hurt your brain yeah yeah it's a little
bit of a mystery but not really okay
that Saturn has a moon that looks just
like the Death Star no [ __ ] it's crying
what me miss it's called Samet no case
call me miss yeah it's called me miss
NASA's Cassini probe was orbiting 31,000
miles above Saturn's atmosphere and was
looking at NEMA switch is one of
Saturn's moons it's made mostly of rock
and water rights and it's almost about
250 miles across which is like not very
far 350 miles that's like from you can
drive that in a car you can drag on the
car yeah I've driven that at her mmm-hmm
it has one side that literally looks
like the Death Star with like that chunk
to crater
yeah I'll show you a picture of it of
the Death Star no yeah let's see the
Death Star Julian are you going to
science.com no I don't know why I'm like
on this where's me Miss Genesis Bing no
I don't are you girl I got stuck on this
look at how many moons look at we got
tightened Rhea no that's me miss me mas
wait me me miss oh maybe it is me mas
that one looks like the dust I thought
they were saying Nima's they're saying
me miss yeah it's me miss em I am it
looks like a nipple Julian what it looks
like a nipple
look at me miss all guys look up me miss
it doesn't look like oh this is so fun
they should make a reality show of all
Saturn's moons we got me miss I pissed
Dione take this Phoebe Phoebe
Hyperion Prometheus can epidural open
doors pretty Janice Janice OS 2009's one
which is a bunch of lines Calypso
Telesto Helene me tone deafness why are
some names like zero one zero one
this boy's name is Polydeuces so okay so
for the naming committee they clearly
have a couple of different people who
work on that committee maybe with
different backgrounds some science some
the opposite of science Oh pan looks
really cool look at pan or pond pin pong
he's a walnut shaped a moon he's cute
look at it Wow
I like pen aren't they cute this is
actually fun look at all these chickens
okay
[Music]
the Cassini probe basically picked up
that it was vibrating or wobbling as a
goes through space which most things
don't usually do it has a crater on one
side yeah
the crater is so big compared to the
size of the moon that if it were on
earth it would be equivalent to the size
of Australia the crater the crater Wow
yeah it's a big boy
it's a crater may yeah but it's also
theorized that if something were to
actually crash into it and can cause
that crater that because it's so small
it should have broken it apart why did
that not break but that it could have
also compacted it even more hmm but that
they call it a an anomaly that's crazy
it actually looks a little bit like the
desk art it looks like a big nipple
mm-hmm but it doesn't look normal it
doesn't look like how you think
because on the moon they're all tiny a
mass anomaly me after I eat a large
pizza I'm a mass anomaly the math
doesn't entirely add up though okay for
it to be a mass anomaly so they've also
theorized that maybe there's something
inside the moon creating it like sucking
the surface in or something well let me
tell you the the other one of the other
moons of Saturn Enceladus and so
Enceladus Enceladus I think that's how
you say Enceladus which is another moon
has a similar wobble which has massive
geysers beneath this surface which give
it a sloshing around action sort of so
it's water so it doesn't look like it's
like a no no no the top is ice yeah and
underneath that surface is water that
those geysers that sort of sloshing
around got inside of it which is giving
it a wobble got a little bit of a water
could justify the movement the vibration
so maybe the same thing is happening on
me miss they're suggesting but it's
almost a billion miles from the Sun so
in order to have liquid water that far
from the Sun because otherwise it would
be ice there has to be some type of heat
source or like a thermal at
Tivoli happening inside the mud the
meanness inside the me miss what the
heck a moon with thermal activity
creating liquid waters really fun right
yeah that's crazy a billion miles from
the Sun million miles from the Sun you
know you used to wake up early for class
and used to shower in the morning used
to get out and it was really cold that's
how it felt you were a billion miles
from the Sun but they would expect to
see some thermal activity or like a
geological activity like a volcano you
have a question I don't know if I have
an answer can I just finish the orbit is
weird though - if it did have liquid
eventually it would orbit Saturn in a
very circular pattern because of the
water mmm
according to these people as opposed but
it has an elliptical orbit why we don't
know beat it so it's going through space
like this in an elliptical orbit and
acting like maybe it might have water
and it but doesn't really act like a
celestial body with water I think it's
so interesting to think about the fact
that there might be water and something
a billion miles from the Sun and what
the [ __ ] that's about because obviously
the vibration can be explained by many
different outcomes right like it doesn't
water's not the only obviously there's
probably a lot of theories right you can
know how to write I don't understand
like there's the you're saying the only
theory as to why this thing is vibrating
is that there's water in it or there's
multiple theories no they don't they
don't know that something like there's
kind of other potential theories that
that might not explain that might
explain the vibration without water
being the answer or whatever I just
think that is the most interesting route
to go down right because like you said
where is the energy source coming from
and why is it not rotating in a perfect
circle yeah I mean they're only
theorizing then maybe it has water
because one of the other moons of Saturn
acts like that it has that yeah but it
also has the geological activity so they
there was probably a heat source inside
of it creating some of the liquid water
hmm but that's why he just goes like
this and he looks like the Death Star
and his name is me miss I like me miss
isn't he cute he's
yeah I still would really like a reality
show with all of Saturn's minutes you
want to look at Jupiter's moons
Jupiter's moons isn't one of them io io
yeah pretty sure
moons of Jupiter Wikipedia fun what are
their names tell us their names we want
to know them yes absolutely I owe you
ropa Oh I think isn't io the one that
like does crazy stuff I think he does
Callisto cute okay yeah sulfur dioxide
Frostwolf fun good times right there's
good times
okay no that's fine I think I would
watch that show probably that was a
reality show they all just have like
different faces the names their names
are accurate but they're just like
different characters based on those
names or it's just the static shot of
all them floating in space and then it
just goes to commercial I would watch
that too
well thank you for providing this
incredibly stimulating podcast of
information and theories and just
conversations it was very fun and my
brain feels protected because I've been
wearing my tinfoil hat so shouts out to
Tim Foyle you know you can postmates
some right now I'm glad you were
protected Marvel is protected for maybe
like a quarter of the podcast nemesis
nemesis those are good theories yeah
those were fun thank you for doing that
you're welcome I hope you guys enjoy Oh
baby you have a hard head don't she
really felt it because she lives life
like her daddy she just goes full force
and rams into things good girl
yeah that's a good girl well thank you
guys for listening and hanging with us I
hope you had your tinfoil hat on and
enjoyed it if you had your tinfoil hat
on while you listen to this podcast
tweet us a picture of you listening the
podcast with your tinfoil hat on it
generally because I want to retweet
we're Tim boiling it out here so you
know you know just hope you guys have a
great week we'll see you on Twitch all
week we're gonna be live all week long
and we'll see you on the next podcast
bye bye
[Music]
[Music]